[Music]
so the current conversation around
Russia's involvement in the u.s.
election I think is quickly unfolding
one and there is a lot of information
that has yet to come to light but
broadly speaking it's not unusual for
Russia in particular and larger
geopolitical powers in general to try to
influence the outcome of elections that
are going to have ramifications for them
on the world stage the United States
certainly continues to do this and has
done this in the past you know Carnegie
Mellon did a really valuable study of
elections from 1946 through to current
day and found that 11 percent of
elections conducted around the world in
every country for that entire period of
time had influence from either Russia or
the United States and 70 percent of
those instances of influence were the
United States rather than Russia this is
something that you know actually when
you think about it it seems almost
irresponsible not to do to a certain
extent so if if the United States has a
perspective around which country is
going to sponsor attacks here in
American territory and which which
candidates in a given government will
not you know clearly the United States
is going to have a perspective there we
see this a recent example of this in the
context of the US would be leadership in
post-conflict Iraq obviously there has
been a lot of interest from Iran and
Shiite forces within the Middle East in
influence now that the government in
Baghdad is more up for grabs post-saddam
era and the United States has a
perspective around how much she had
influenced Washington would like to see
in Baghdad that's one example
every election in every
major strategic territory around the
world the United States Russia and most
other world powers have a perspective
around which candidate they would like
to see win and which they wouldn't now
the extent to which a government is
willing to push that perspective on the
electorate of that country is a matter
of law and there are lines that when a
foreign power steps over them they're in
breach of international law
there are certainly instances of every
major world power including our own
having overstepped those lines in the
last century less so in recent years the
United States has moved away from that
habit over the last few decades
Russia has returned to it with great
gusto particularly in the form of
information warfare what we you know
come to know as fake news and that's we
are just seeing the very very beginning
tip of the iceberg there you know we're
already seeing artificial intelligence
and computer programs that are able to
take based on a small Bank of words and
a few images any world leader and have
them convincingly say on video whatever
the program would like them to say these
these bots are just in their infancy and
the notion of to see is to believe and
video clips is being compelling evidence
of truth is is something that is
unfortunately of a bygone era and Russia
is extremely advanced in that technology
so this is the this is early days and I
think rather than expect any world power
and Russia in particular to back off on
these kinds of attempts we need to
expect our own leaders to have the
integrity to do what's right even when
no one's watching when when I trained in
service for the US government the inside
of our manual said integrity is doing
what's right when nobody is watching and
the the temptation to yield to influence
in exchange for power is built-in to
representative democracy and it by the
way it's not just foreign powers like
Russia and Moscow it's our own special
interests in this country which can
yield influence that can be just as
damaging and so this is not an issue
that's going to go away for us I don't
think we're going to be able to you know
beef up our our cybersecurity over the
next couple of years and bid this threat
farewell and so while we will continue
to be vigilant against it in every way
that we can I think we also need to rely
on ourselves and our leadership to fend
off that temptation if it does make it
through the barricades and present
itself in the room when nobody's
watching
you